-Performing "El Nene"
and "Sufro"
from his new album,
"Las Leyendas Nunca Mueren 2,"
here's Anuel AA.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Uy ♪
♪ Dame el teléfono, gánate
mi confianza, si no, vete ♪
♪ Tus amigá te aconsejan
mal como si son las
que te lo meten ♪
♪ Ya tú eres mayor de edad y
todavía andá comprando jugueté ♪
♪ Uy, hey, hey ♪
♪ Yo soy el nene ♪
♪ Demuéstrame que tú me amá,
yo te prometo mañana ♪
[ Singing in Spanish ]
♪ Ay, ohh, ay, ay, uy ♪
♪ Yo le pedí a dios que
de mi vida saque al falso ♪
♪ My...se viró y ahora pá
él yo tengo un carbon ♪
[ Singing in Spanish ]
♪ Ella quiere un malo y yo la
quiero encima de mí brincando ♪
♪ Como Young Thug y YFN Lucci,
yo vivo guerreando ♪
♪ Yo soy el nene, pacá encima
de más pacá de ciené ♪
♪ Yo te mamo ese toto, bebé,
y en mi boca te viené, brr ♪
♪ Si yo perdonara,
yo andará con el diablo ♪
♪ Baby, no me fallé a mí,
es primero tú ♪
[ Singing in Spanish ]
♪ Toy puesto pá ti,
tú eres mía y de nadie má ♪
♪ Si yo perdonara, no andará ♪
♪ Haciendo lo que te dé... ♪
♪ Pero, bebé, no puedo mentir,
tú me poné... ♪
♪ Toy puesto pá ti,
tú eré mía y de nadie má ♪
♪ Brr, brr ♪
♪ Yo soy el nene, ay, ay ♪
[ Speaking Spanish ]
Brr. Unh.
♪ Yo no sufro por mujereé,
menos por dinero ♪
♪ Un tiroteo llega y lleno
los peines de nuevo ♪
♪ Los pié en la tierra,
la mente en el cielo ♪
♪ La baby me está diciendo
que quiere... ♪
♪ Yo soy un diablo
desde que nací ♪
♪ Vendiendo drogá,
así fue que crecí ♪
♪ Donde se crian demonió... ♪
♪ La calle é una serie
y cada muerte... ♪
♪ Yo soy así ♪
♪ Siempre he sido así ♪
♪ Guerreando yo me voá morir ♪
♪ Los peiné tós tienen refill ♪
♪ Brr ♪
Tengo una glopeta que é rápida y
lenta porque vino con el botón.
La coca de Bolivia se la vendemó
a los domí en Nueva York.
[ Speaking Spanish ]
-♪ Sufro ♪
[ Singing in Spanish ]
♪♪
♪ Brr ♪
[ Speaking Spanish ]
[ Cheers and applause ]